Well, here it is.
I must say, the idea of placing
my member into this hole
to be pleasured
by some mystery woman
has me excited, yes,
but also pretty nervous.
Here we go.
[clears throat]
[zipper unzips]
[exhales]
So far, uh...
nothing to report.
♪ ♪
Oh, sorry.
Just using the glory hole.
(Forrest)
I had arrived a bit early,
but once the sun went down
and the park
was officially closed,
the glory hole
was officially open.
The name was right.
It was glorious.
The woman behind that stall
had a talent
well beyond anything
I had ever experienced...
Oh, wow.
(Forrest)
Well beyond anything my ex-wife
had demonstrated
on any of my birthdays.
Wow.
(Forrest)
I returned the next night
and the night after that,
and on each occasion,
the glory was equally glorious.
There was etiquette
to consider...
Whoa, excuse me.
- I'm next for the glory hole.
- Hey, man.
(Forrest)
But in general, I found
no downside to the glory hole.
Myself and the other men
enjoying this woman's talents
were experiencing
sexual intimacy at its best.
I was completely satisfied
without having to cater
to my partner's pleasure.
I knew it would be a violation
of the spirit of the glory hole
to meet the generous woman
on the other side
of that partition,
but wasn't it
equally unforgivable
to let the chance
to meet her pass?
Yes, it was.
Oh, I'm sorry.
The woman who was just in here,
did you see where she went?
No.
(Forrest)
I began spending
all my spare time in the park
searching for my mystery mouth.
And then, it happened.
- Hey there.
- Hi.
I've been seeing you here
a bunch lately.
- [laughing]
- It's funny.
Yeah.
I'm Forrest.
- I'm Lynn.
- Her name was Lynn.
(Forrest)
She was a PhD student
and exactly the sort
of sweet-natured person who,
it seemed to me, would
selflessly pleasure strange men
through the partition
of a bathroom stall.
Hey, I got
a crazy question for you.
Hmm?
Are you the woman
in the glory hole?
I have been putting
my erect penis in that hole
for the past week, and I just
thought I recognized you.
Wait, hang on.
(Forrest)
Was she the wrong woman,
or was she indeed
the maven of the stall?
I would never know.
In most relationships,
there is a wall of some sort
keeping two people
from truly seeing each other.
A glory hole
makes that wall literal,
but it doesn't
make the experience
any less meaningful.
Glory holes,
4 1/2 stars.
You never did find
the woman
behind that glory hole,
did you, Forrest?
Sadly, no,
I did not.
I have a feeling you never will.